air pollutants represent a major risk to  public health and contribute to climate  change and global warming Road Transport  accounts for a significant amount of the  EU total emissions of greenhouse gases  to help drivers choose new cars with  lower emissions of pollutants the EU  will soon introduce a real driving  emissions test able to measure a car's  emissions in the same driving conditions  as the ones encountered on the road this  test will be conducted in addition to  the other mandatory laboratory tests  already carried out in the European  Union before a car manufacturer can  obtain approval for a particular model